hey chris bassett da's opening night
starter his first ever
opener of the season and he pitched one
into the sixth inning against the
houston astros here's the pitch to bets
a right-handed hitter and that's a swing
and a comebacker knocked down by bassett
flips over to first for the out and
that's the way our ball game begins two
odds nobody on top of the first inning
justin turner two for six for him in the
series opener passing turns and fires
and turner watches a curve swats it to
right center carrying towards the gap
and it's down
justin turner with a two-out hit he's
headed to second with a double
so hit by the pitch is muncie and now
the dodgers with two on and two out oh
aj pollock the left fielder and the
one-two pitch on the way swung on a miss
got him with a breaking ball away and
pass it works out of it second start of
the year for clayton kershawn opening
day not his usual self he gave up six
runs in the hitters paradise that is
coors field 2-2 again he went around
and a pitch that bounced and his
strikeouts opened his night
one away for lowry
left center and hit pretty well pollock
going back and that babies off the top
of the wall
lowered a second with a double just
missed hitting one out of here off
kershaw
so here's ramon lauriano
this one is driven right center field
that's on the move he's not gonna get it
it's gonna knock it around as larry will
score
and the ace for the first time in 2021
they lead in a game it's one nothing
athletics kershaw's 2-2
got him swinging
back-to-back sliders to get chapman and
kershaw with strikeouts for each of the
first two hours kershaw trying to limit
the damage to juan here in the first
home with another 0-2 to murphy gets him
swinging with the slider
winds up getting three strikeouts
swinging in this first inning now
trouble as for la they have first and
second and nobody out and the catcher
austin barnes coming up
barnes yanks one to left that's a fair
ball that drops near the corner canna
race is over to grab it rios headed home
to tie the game barnes hustles into
second with a double
[Applause]
oakland's first lead and only lead of
the year
is gone and austin barnes makes sure of
it up the mookie bets here with one out
[Applause]
orlando's got it he's gonna come home
tag play and murphy would he hang on yes
he did what a great point
so moreland could not hesitate he had to
make a decision and go with it and he
did
seeger and get a base hit somewhere now
mookie's got a great chance to score
from second
hit hard and it's fair nice play by
moreland he throws bounce it gets their
side retired what a play by mitch
moreland what an inning defensively for
the veteran mitch morrell and he saves
two runs right he's swinging miss at it
in the first inning with those three k's
one two
already his fourth strikeout and similar
characteristics to that one too
well it looks like he's got the one that
he can throw in leaving the strike zone
and have a sharp break and it looks like
he's got the other one where he can make
it look like a strike and end up the
ball
the turner four for his last four and
now max muncie to the plate one-two
pitch to munson he swings and he hammers
one to right this one toward the corner
this one is gone a home run two-run shot
for max muncie his first of the year and
the dodgers take the lead three to one
he gets on top of this one he doesn't
pop it up he doesn't put too much top
spin on it that it doesn't get out of
here
takes the short porch and hits it long
here comes the pitch to
now
rios
gets into one way back to right center
it's gone
first of the season for rios
monsieur rios both going deep
and the lead goes the full one a curve
ball that hangs up there
this one doesn't even make it back to
the waist you can see that edwin was
slightly out in front there's a 171 era
against the a's overall in five prior
starts one of them at dodger stadium
a one 1-3-5
did he get him to swing he did says
adrian johnson he threw a ball in the
dirt another slider
and murphy chased it another strikeout
for kershaw
swinging off long fly by biscotti deep
down the line and left home run distance
for sure in the second deck but he
pulled it foul
did he
what's the call home run
home run piscotty johnson and gorman
looking at each other nobody said
anything but scotty's gonna round the
bases and he's gonna touch home and the
aisle get one back
i think and it is a crew chief review
bob melvin not happy that we've even
gotten this far in the process
even on replay this is going to be hard
pretty hard to tell
clayton said it was foul
that was quick
and a foul ball
it's a foul ball and he's got to go back
to the plate against kershaw here's the
pitch 0-2 is bounce towards shortness to
step to his left is seeger and he throws
onto first base to get biscotti and the
oakland fans showering the umpiring crew
with their thoughts pass it from the
stretch kicks deliverers and a breaking
ball waved at the big motion by faster
than the slow breaking ball at 73.
rios case that'll bring up lux and right
now bass are trying to keep these in
this game maybe
you're not going to be down there
could be two
chapman with a nice play and they do
turn the double play
chapman had to handle a difficult feat
to mark cannon who's over two tonight
strikeout ground out
and he swings and hits a high fly ball
shadow left over toward the line out is
seeger in comes pollock pollock makes
the catch
one away for the a's in the sixth
lowry in the air to deep center field
bets on the run back to the track shy of
the wall makes the catch two away
they had to go a long way to get there
took the perfect route and lowry is out
two gone
top weekly
kershaw just keeps on mowing him down
muncie puts it away and on nine pitches
kershaw with a one two three six
he stays right in that lane with great
tempo here he comes again and he strikes
out chapman
the slider again for his seventh k
now sean murphy
another strikeout for kershaw
back to back haze to open the seventh
he's got eight total tonight first base
runner for the a's since the third
inning
[Music]
bouncing ball to first muncie takes it
to the bag clayton kershaw seven
splendid innings tonight 4-1 in the
ninth inning back to the top and mookie
betts there's one for four eighth pitch
coming
and that's it's a high drive to left
center field way back there and gone
mookie's first of the year third of the
night for the dodgers they lead 5-1
well he got all of it a fan who brought
his glove had to reach over the very top
railing
not a bad pitch either it was down and
away
156 career home run for mookie bets
scotty to the walk and they're at the
corners
2-1 pitch
[Music]
popped into shallow center field
running catch by gavin lexton the game
the dodgers win at 5-1 their fifth
consecutive win